we begin with breaking news out of
Pakistan former prime minister Imran
Khan has been arrested by police backed
by paramilitary officers at a court in
the capital Islamabad Khan who has
ousted as leader a year ago is facing
dozens of charges including corruption
and terrorism all of which he says are
politically motivated
let's speak to Kamal heisner who joins
us live from the Pakistani capital is
lamabad has this arrest at this time
come out come as a shock
not just the way that the the time of
the arrest but the way of the arrest
because Imran Khan had already gone into
the court premises it was inside the
court premises when those rangers units
which is a part of the Pakistani
military but under the jurisdiction of
the Interior Ministry broke the windows
entered into that room then picked up
Imran Khan his lawyer said that they
were pepper sprayed that the former
prime minister was kicked and also hit
on the head and then he was taken away
from inside the court premises which
then prompted the Chief Justice of the
Islamabad high court to say as to how he
could have been arrested from inside the
jurisdiction of that court now he then
called The Inspector General and said he
should appear within 15 minutes the
Inspector General was late however the
Inspector General said that it was not
the police who arrested him but the
paramilitary forces who were aiding the
national accountability Bureau that
arrested him the uh the song about High
Court chief justice also summoned the
secretary interior within 15 minutes he
has not turned up yet the court also
disturbed about that Imran Khan
according to the latest reports has been
taken away by the national
accountability Bureau today
premises and there he will be given a
medical examination with eight doctors
on board but however as the reports of
Imran Khan's arrest went across the
country protesters are already on the
streets arrests are being made the
Inspector General police of Islamabad is
saying that anybody coming out to
protest should be arrested so indeed a
precarious situation developing after
the arrest of the former prime minister
absolutely because I Duke provides a
little bit of context a little bit of
background because there have been
arrest attempts in the past which have
been prevented by Imran Khan supporters
foreign
Khan's supporters but also backed up by
the courts because the courts were
granting him bail there were incidents
earlier outside his residence in which
the protesters tried to stop the police
from arresting Imran Khan because he
already had bail now he's got over a
hundred and forty over 140 cases against
him this new case with the national
accountability Bureau says pertains to
some fraud in some University that was
done in the past however Imran Khan's
lawyers said they did not receive any
notices in this regard and also the fact
that Imran Khan has been cooperating
with the courts despite the threat to
his life there was an assassination
attempt on him several months ago he has
been coming under heavy uh body
protective armor with his close
bodyguards along with him to the course
and has said that there's been at least
another attempt to try to assassinate
him when he lost appeared in the
judicial complex so indeed a precarious
situation also exacerbated by the fact
that the government in power uh has
already said that they will not uh be
holding those elections with the Supreme
Court says have to be held within 90
days those that deadline is going to
pass soon but what will be important to
see is how the people react to this
latest it is absolutely we'll be keeping
a very close eye on events as they
unfold that in Pakistan for the moment
thanks very much
well Imran Khan spokesman has told down
to zero that this arrest is unlawful and
the supporters are responding
accordingly
uh chairman Khan has been has been sort
of talking about uh the prospect of his
arrest you know for a number of years
and even this morning before leaving for
Islamabad he recorded a video message
you know which he said that he would
most likely be arrested again and this
in fact you know every time he appeared
in a court of law uh uh his followers
are nowhere afraid that he would be
taken in and I think attempts are made
in the past but uh uh because of various
factors you know he was not arrested but
today it was a blatant interference in
the judicial Affairs by the powers that
be and he was taken in uh well let's see
what the reaction is going to be but
this is this is in violation of all all
laws and rules contained in the statute
book you know and I I think
um the Rangers uh were the personal that
took him and and I we understand you
know that that they're not directly
controlled by the government and power
they are controlled by other forces you
know which are considered to be above
the law in this market in this country I
understand you know that in certain
cities you know large number of people
are already uh Gathering and they are
going to understand if they're going to
block the cities so I think that will
happen you know and this is going to
catch up you know as time progresses you
know and we we learn about this
whereabouts you know it could be that uh
protests are also taken to the PACE
where he is kept uh in confinement
um so you know various various you know
uh our leadership party leadership at uh
at the Grassroots level you know they
are taking the initiative they're taking
the steps you know to to Galvanize
people to to to to to launch protests
let's bring in Paul Washer Khan she's a
member of the ruling Pakistan people's
party and a member of the National
Assembly and she joins us now from
Islamabad via Skype good to have you
with us Paul Washer perhaps you can shed
some light for us on why Imran Khan has
been arrested today
when he has been uh he has a number of
cases registered against him this is one
of those cases where he did not have a
pre-arrest bail this is an arrest by the
national accountability Bureau as far as
I know so far and uh the national
accountability Bureau has its own
standard operating procedures with
regards to arrests but please
um uh keep in uh I would like to
highlight the issue that the current
government has already passed a law that
makes the
laws that govern the national
accountability Bureau far less harsher
than they were during a grand fund's
time when a number of the opposition
leaders and uh
going off topic here what I'm trying to
understand is Imran Khan was in court he
was facing trial for a one of the cases
that has been brought against him so why
do these paramilitary forces storm the
courtroom and pull him out to put him
behind bars when he was working through
the process of justice anyway
since I said there are a number of cases
so as far as I understand this was
totally another case in which he did not
have pain and the paramilitary force
reports to the ministry of so it is
generally under the ministry of interior
not under the uh under the military so
it is uh it has must have sought
permission from the ministry of interior
before acting but what about permission
from the judge who is in that course
sorry did it seek permission from the
judge who was in that Court who was
trying Imran Khan
permission from the judge who is in
court because this is not the case that
was being heard in court this was
totally another case in which it had
been issued several notices and he
failed to either respond or appear in
person as was required as has been the
practice of everybody who has been
arrested by national accountability
Bureau during his own term and power
most of the arrests that were made
imbran's terms were in under the
national accountability bureau's act
which was much harsher than what it is
now okay okay yes yes we heard that
point before but imman Khan is saying
that all these cases against him are
politically motivated he says the
government is determined to put him
behind bars no matter what do you see
how this action today just plays into
that narrative
no it does not you see these are solid
cases there are cases of foreign funding
this is the case of a huge sums of uh
money that have been embezzled and he
fails to appear and defend himself you
see even if it is a case is politically
motivated Let's uh for a second you know
agree to what he says uh isn't it
supposed to be uh the case that you come
and you defend yourself nobody is above
the law in Pakistan people have been uh
held behind bars for years and forgotten
about in frivolous cases okay
he has been arrested for not appearing
to defend himself but in this particular
instance he was in court to defend
himself
you see but I'm trying to explain to you
that was another case he has to
understand that but why not let justice
justice run its course
sorry why not let Justice run its course
we are trying to it has nothing to do
with the government for one number two
this is an independent uh uh a bureau of
accountability it does not come under
the government's Jewish jurisdiction in
any case and the third thing is that he
should appear he has failed to appear uh
before courts he has awaited arrests he
uses medical conditions he uses the uh
you know privilege charges against uh uh
the law enforcement the military the
government but he does not want to
appear before a court of law
it has nothing to do with the government
who who controls as paramilitary Rangers
group
I am I tried to explain that to you
earlier also that the paramilitary
ranges group comes under the ministry of
interior which is a under the government
of Pakistan it's a civil uh Ministry who
arrested him
they are uh they can be uh asked for by
the ministry of interior and they're at
their back and call
but she said it had nothing to do with
the government and yes they were
arrested by paramilitary groups who
respond to the ministry of the interior
images can be asked to come anywhere if
there is a Law and Order situation that
is the purvy of the ministry of interior
the case has nothing to do with the
Pakistani government of Pakistan it has
it has to do with the national
accountability Bureau where he has
failed to appear on a number of
occasions and in the past such leniency
was not shown to his own opponents do
you fear for the impact that this is
going to have on Pakistan we're already
seeing his supporters taking to the
street this is going to cause huge
upheaval and divisions in the country
you see uh Imran Khan has been driving
divisions since about a year
now you have seen as as uh have all the
others and the people of Pakistan to the
numbers that come out with him in case
of a call for uh protests are not that
great so let's see uh it has nothing to
do with how the national accountability
Bureau operates but he will definitely
try and get his people out but in the
past even a few days ago there was a
call and that failed miserable so let's
see how many people come out on this
well we are already seeing live pictures
of people out on the streets protesting
so pal we will keep a very close eye on
the situation there in Pakistan thanks
very much for joining us